ahead of these strikes you express some
concern about their impact you said that
they could pose a risk to patient safety
how has it been so far with one more day
to go
so I think the picture is that a
combination of planning that NHS
managers put into preparing for this
week and the willingness of other
members of Staff Consultants other
medical staff to step into the shoes of
Junior doctors means that we have
managed
reasonably well in terms of urgent and
emergency care
but the other side of the story is that
in order to do that we've had to cancel
thousands of appointments and operations
so for example yesterday I was in a
hospital on a surgical Ward
that was
being basically staffed along with
obviously the nurses another staff but
staff by consultants and and they were
coping well morale was was reasonable
but they were all aware of the fact that
while they were on the ward filling in
for roles that Junior doctrines would
normally undertake their lists of
appointments our operations was getting
longer
so are you reassured though that patient
safety hasn't been compromised that's
what hospitals are telling you
I think broadly speaking as I say I
think we've coped uh pretty well uh this
week
um but I think it's really important to
say that when we talk about patient
safety yes there's a kind of immediate
issue uh I'll be able to see people in
emergency departments for example
um and yes I think we've been able to do
that pretty well this week but also
there's an impact on patient safety uh
when uh an outpatient appointment is
canceled or when an operation is delayed
and so certainly in those terms those
hundreds of thousands of canceled
operations and appointments will have
had an impact on patient safety and
that's why
as these strikes come to an end and that
is a relief to us it's vitally important
that we don't have further strikes and
that the two sides in this dispute do
get into negotiation which is why it is
we've been calling from the beginning of
this week for acas the conciliation
service to be invited to get involved
and find a basis and decides to talk
well yes and yet we heard from Chris
philp the government Minister yesterday
as far as that was concerned saying that
the BMA had to call off the strikes
first we've also had calls from the
health secretary that the BMA should
drop its initial 35 demand before they
spring in acas do you think that's fair
enough
uh and I mean it's a I think I have the
same sense that many members of the
public I've spoken to in NHS leaders
have which is
you know why do we negotiate we
negotiate because neither side is
willing to accept the starting point to
the other side and you know of course at
the moment neither side is willing to
accept the starting point at the other
side but let's get into negotiation and
uh the sooner we do the better I think
the BMA to be fair have indicated that
35 is their starting point and they've
also indicated they'd be willing to talk
to acaps so I do think now it's up to
the government to take that step to
engage acas to find the basis for talks
because there is the threat of more
strike days and one message I heard very
very clearly this week you know visiting
a hospital yesterday talking to hospital
leaders all week is that another set of
strikes will mean that it becomes almost
impossible for the Health Service to
meet the really challenging targets that
it's set for reducing the number of
people for example on waiting lists
meanwhile the nursing unions will
announce the results of their ballots
today they've been putting the
government's offer to their members
um the times is reporting today that the
Royal College of Nursing they say that
it's likely that their members will have
rejected the offer How concerned are you
about that
well that obviously would be very
disappointing news and I would say that
if that is the case and it's speculation
at this stage but if that is the case I
would really encourage the trade unions
and the government to immediately get
into talks obviously the Gap is not huge
according to the times if that how if
the if the offer has been rejected it's
by a relatively small amount so the Gap
isn't that big so let's get straight
back into talks let's see if we can uh
find enough to get this uh over the line
what would really worry me would be if
we saw further strikes from our nursing
colleagues and we saw as it were people
getting back into entrenched positions
because an NHS coping with Junior doctor
strike and Strikes and possibly the
renewal of strikes by other Staffing
including nurses well you know that that
will make the situation extremely
difficult
and on a practical level what do you
think would happen if one nursing union
accepted the offer and the other
rejected it because there are two um two
unions who are coming back with their
ballot results today practically what
happens in that scenario
well I think as the RCN is the the
largest Union uh if it is rejected uh
then it means that the unions will not
have uh will have a mandate to reopen
negotiations and see if they can get a
better deal and and as I say I think the
important thing if that is the case is
that is that what happens is the sites
get together quickly and see what we can
do to close
um the remaining Gap and not that as it
were the side to withdraw to where they
were before talk started um a few weeks
ago and we get back into an entrenched
position I don't think you know clearly
uh whilst I understand uh how nurses
feel but clearly a rejection is that it
is bad news and and it is of concern so
we need to try to respond to this
creatively so that we can avoid further
industrial action
okay well um Matthew Taylor as we say we
await the results of those ballots it's
not clear yet how nurses will have voted
but Matthew Taylor from the NHS
Confederation we appreciate your time
this morning thanks so much thank you